[Music]
your husband is from Australia is that
right so he's Australian yeah so do you
visit his family a lot we do we do if
we're lucky we get there a couple of
times a year we love it there I have to
say it's uh very the people there I was
there once I was in Sydney uh back in
the old NBC days they sent me for one of
the Olympics and I loved I love the
people there but boy is it a different
culture oh my God and they and they
shorten everything I I they're they're
actually very lazy speakers and I can
say this because I'm married to one half
all my friends are Aussies but they they
certainly not only shorten their
sentences but they shorten their words
like for example I went there when my
very first trips there I was watching
their national news and it was the
equivalent of Tom Brokaw and I wish I
could do an Aussie accent I can't right
but I the guy the guy said oh it's going
to be a scorcher out there make sure you
bring your sunnies to brecky and I was
like to my husband what on Earth is he
saying he's a news man on the national
news and I'm thinking the children watch
this and I said can you translate that
for me and he said yeah make sure you
you bring your sunglasses to breakfast
because it's going to be really hot out
there tomorrow and I was like wow that's
that's amazing so we're not raising our
children in Australia because only you
learned a quarter of the English
language yeah it's also really stupid
breaking yeah yeah
it's gonna be sunny out tomorrow isn't
that great like there's not anything
else that they really have to worry
about there it's like no I've got those
countries I've noticed everyone there
was incredibly fit that's what I know
yeah I was walking around and everybody
yeah guys or anything any like the
anything any bar anything they're doing
they're all they all have the v-shaped
torsos and they're they're like doing
gymnastics it's true and then they drink
like 30 pints of beer it's the only
country that in England where you can
get away you can go to lunch and it's
okay to drink a bottle of wine and go
back to work right it's amazing maybe I
will raise my kids there
really good Mom thank you uh we have a
clip here uh from True Detective and you
are uh play the part of Woody
Harrelson's wife that's correct and uh
Woody and Matthew McConaughey are our
partners who are very different one of
the things I love about this show is
among many things is that they're so
you've seen a million partner uh shows
about Partners detectives who are
partners and these guys they've put a
new spin on it they're very different
and uh you actually have a very
difficult time being the wife of that
that's exactly Woody Harrelson yeah and
this particular scene is they they go
out to dinner I played a bit of a
Matchmaker with uh Matthew's character
and uh my woody departs dinner early and
I'm calling Matthew at the end of the
night to find out if he knows where my
husband went to and to see how his date
went all right let's take a look at this
clip from True Detective
you drop a you drop Jen at home
you can go in
ah no look she's nice pretty
Comfort there rest
I think you guys would be good together
if you gave it a chance
I don't
give things chances I don't know why
that is that's because we know what we
want
and we don't mind being alone
you'll be home take care
that is a hard guy to set up